we turn now to the aftermath of the mass
shooting in Dayton Ohio it happened
early yesterday about 13 hours after the
El Paso attack hundreds of people
attended a vigil in Dayton last night in
honor of the nine people killed and 27
hurt there during the vigil the crowd
interrupted remarks by Governor Mike
DeWine by chanting do something LNG is
in Dayton mola what more are we learning
about this shooting
well good morning Anthony the shooting
happened here in the popular and
typically lively Oregon district just
after 1:00 a.m. on Sunday the bars here
on Fifth Street
were packed with people among them Gavin
I think he just turned 21 years old and
as he tells us it was his first time at
a bar he barely got out alive all I can
hear the screams for those people and
I'll never forget that
Gavin Ivey was listening to music with
friends Saturday night when the rapid
gunfire began there was a shot that went
about 3 feet so left my head I might
even like my heart sank like I was I
thought I was gonna die you saw people
falling around you yes this surveillance
video shows the moment people near the
shooter ducked for cover or ran mass
chaos ensued carnage all around police
say the gunman Connor Betts arrived in
the Oregon district with his sister and
a friend
parking his car here just after 1:00
a.m. he killed his first victim here in
an alleyway he then entered East 5th
Street and killed eight other victims
including his sister within
approximately 30 seconds six officers
took him down in front of the barn ed
peppers if police had not stopped him
and he made it into that establishment
where hundreds of people were dancing
and enjoying yeah we would have had
hundreds of people die nan Whaley is the
mayor of Dayton
that's a safe area super safe you had
police all over the place
presence isn't it takeaway that this
could happen anytime anywhere absolutely
you know and we have to ask why when is
enough enough police say the gunman was
wearing a mask a bulletproof vest
hearing protection and armed with
illegally obtained ar-15 like rifle he
ordered online from Texas and picked up
at a local firearms dealer he also had a
100 round drum magazine the victims
range in age from 22 to 57 the youngest
the shooters own sister Megan batts the
other victims include Louis Oglesby a
mother of two girls one born just a few
weeks ago Ivy says he feels extremely
lucky that he and his friends are alive
I still don't get it bad things don't
really happen and Dayton Ohio see things
on my news but when something happens in
your hometown it's it hits hard six of
the nine people who were killed here
were black but police have not yet
determined a motive have not made that
announcement quite yet now police say
the shooter prior to this only had minor
run-ins with the law but sources tell
CBS News that in high school he created
a hit list and that included women who
rejected him romantically
Jericka Mona thank you